[Music]
you were having a very pleasant
day
blessed then someone Reigns on our
parade removed one cancer just to find
another this is not the conversation we
should be having right
now we going after a CIA asset that's
been captured this your first mission in
theater jte second do me a favor keep up
the last thing we need in this office
have to save your
ass the hell are these guys welcome
Miss yo hand over in five I'm
ready I am your eyes in the sky and the
bringer of duel
subtle I got Movement we got a situation
RPC 12:00
incoming weapons a
Reaper you there reap we're here Playboy
you got to get your ass on the move Son
come on
Soldier hang in there
okay blackberg can you stay in the area
D him aort
aort Playboy are you injured can't talk
right now I get it this is not where you
want to be okay it's not here it's not
here it's
here three hostiles heading your way do
not move there's no way I am off this
op remember you
training this is going to get
[Music]
ugly our priority is protecting the men
and women you serve this country 5 4 3
two
[Music]
one you got to move man get up and
go